Жилет репортера "Нової газети" на вівці -
у клітці перед редакцією видання у Москві.
Це не зоопарк, а остання кампанія залякування
відомої російської опозиційної газети.
Кількома днями раніше в редакцію принесли відрізану баранячу голову
а жалобний вінок з фотографією
журналіста-розслідувача Дениса Короткова.
З вересня Коротков працює у "Новій газеті".
Навіть у цій кав'ярні в центрі Cанкт-Петербурга
він відчуває, що за ним стежать.
В інтернеті проти Короткова розгорнули масштабну кампанію цькування -
усе через його рослідування діяльності "кухаря Кремля"
і друга Путіна Євгена Пригожина,
який керує фабрикою тролів і приватною військовою компанією "Вагнер".
Саме російських найманців стосувалися останні статті Короткова.
Викладають в інтернет мої адреси, дані моїх родичів,
членів моєї родини, радять, що зі мною треба зробити.
Сказати, що через це мені приємно й радісно - то, звісно, ні.
Звичайно, мені це неприємно і нерадісно.
Чи відчував я, отримавши такі погрози, певне задоволення,
що, очевидно, написав усе правильно - так.
У редакції в Москві триває щоденна летючка.
"Новая газета" - одне з останніх у Росії незалежних ЗМІ.
Уже 25 років часопис відомий своїми розслідуваннями
про корупцію і порушення прав людини.
Його співробітники відчувають на собі
дедалі більші обмеження свободи преси в Росії.
Уже шість журналістів газети заплатили життям
за право займатися своєю професією.
Серед них – Анна Політковська.
Відому журналістку вбили в 2005-му.
Вона стала відомою передусім статтями про Чечню.
За які їй часто погрожували.
Не дивно, що відчуття страху нависає над співробітниками редакції.
Майже завжди.
Ми зазнали таких же втрат, як на війні.
Журналістські втрати - як на війні.
У мирний час.
Так що це як мінне поле, по якому ми ходимо.
Якщо обирати між тим, надсилатимуть голову барана
чи конкретно нічого не скажуть, але прийдуть і вб'ють,
то нехай хоч щодня присилають по баранячій голові.
Хоча провладна спілка журналістів Росії й засуджує
загрози на адресу ЗМІ,  але в цілому позитивно
оцінює стан свободи преси в країні.
І журналісти, і влада - кожен зі свого боку
вчиться спілкуватися один з одним.
І хоча існують проблеми, перегиби та близькі до цензури порушення,
попри це, у цілому ситуація прокращується.
І загальна картина має цілком пристойний вигляд на загальносвітовому рівні.
Сам Денис Коротков не думає, що його робота аж така небезпечна.
Раніше він працював у поліції, але сім років тому
вирішив стати журналістом.
Ризики роботи журналіста-розслідувача він сприймає як належне,
хоча нещодавно навіть його донька отримала погрози через татові статті.
Мені цікаво розслідувати те, що не видно людському оку,
те, що не лежить поверхні.
А таємні справи – майже завжди це злочинні справи.
Звичайно, з такою роботою можна стати в позу і сказати,
що "ніколи і ніщо мене не зупинить"...
Дай Боже, щоб мої опоненти цю мою межу ніколи не відчули.
Денис Коротков відмовляється розповідати,
про що буде його наступне розслідування для "Нової газети".
Але каже, що після публікації очікує нових погроз.